Okay.
Hi folks.
Be live here.
Short stream today. I have a bunch of
meetings and things to attend to.
Um
I want to keep doing some stuff on
offpaul.
Been thinking a lot about core
algorithm. ton of stuff to go through.
Um, first thing I want to do,
I want to look at
want to look at our current
vantage estimate.
This is clipped important sampling.
This is actually this algorithm I've
come up with is very similar to retrace.
Didn't realize that.
Now the question I have is am I actually
computing the important sampling
correctly?
Come on.
Okay, here um
ratio
No, wait, wait. So, you sample your
data, right?
And then you compute the ratio.
Okay, I actually think that this is
correct.
I think I I've basically come up with
retrace and applied it to on policy. So
it's the ratio of
new policy to old policy, right?
New policy minus old policy. So yeah,
this turns into
this is the same as new log props
divided by the same as new props divide
by old props, right?
So I have actually come up with
something that's almost identical to
retrace here.
So it's ne gamma v next
minus values of t. So gamma this is v
next.
Okay. So this is
this is pretty much it.
expectation over
pi is a little weird, but I think this
is pretty much
this is pretty much the algorithm that I
So the probability under the old policy
versus the new policy is sketchy because
you have this epsilon greedy thing with
um
with off policy work, right?
look at a few other there are a few
other papers I wanted to look at Now,
on.
Okay.
Funny that we actually have uh faster
performance than this.
Yeah, the Atari uh being faster is
but we really haven't optimized for
Atari
because this thing like you get
bottlenecked more by the environment
than anything.
Wait, but does this have anything about
off policy
Couple the acting batch size learning
batch size.
This still has the off policy problems,
doesn't it?
only the slow environments. This really
doesn't do all that much.
Yeah. So, this is basically just Yeah.
TPUs are fast.
Congratulations.
Yeah. So they use an entire freaking pod
to solve pong.
I don't know why I was linked this paper
as like something useful.
They do anything for off policy.
The whole pod
2048 cores. I think it's eight or 16
cores per, but still it's a stupid
amount of compute for Pong.
I mean, unless these are in lock step,
right?
Yeah. But these can't be in lock step.
I don't think this does anything other
than um
yeah, this really doesn't do anything
other than screw up
uh your data. This is off policy
I think Costa's implementation of this
allows you to lag exactly one step
behind. So, it's not that off policy,
but ideally like
you're still playing with fire doing
this.
Let me check some of the other papers.
to clean out. Cool. They actually have a
bunch of algorithms here.
Oh, this is a totally different
Yeah, this is a totally different thing.
This is very silly. Yeah, this is very,
very silly. We don't have to care about
this.
combo pul.
Yeah, I don't like that.
We'll keep making this more and more
freaking complicated architecture.
Okay, so this paper is actually a useful
reference. Um, but the question, right,
hang on. Does this use
efficient online reinforcement learning
with offline data? Why would you do it
this way instead of the other way
around?
Oh, this ensemble thing is Why do people
keep doing this? That's such a freaking
mess. Hang on. Let me Let me see if I
can figure out
They do I don't understand where the uh
the multiple critics come. Hang on.
where do they talk about multiple
critics?
Yeah, layer being a key to this is
crazy. Okay.
Large ensembles are
the heck.
Uh, I thought we got rid of this jank.
But like regardless, it's combine online
and offline updates. They have a way to
do this.
Um, is this what we want?
of the repo in the process of
experimenting with
standard dempling is different. It's uh
quite a bit different. It's a
combination of online and offline.
I'm trying to think though now what I
want to
go after because basically I figured out
that the advantage estimate that I have
is already basically the one that we
just turns out that the work that I did
on puffer advantage is very similar to
retrace
very very similar
also I've got a call in a half hour only
really do short stream today I might
leave stream up and then come back for
an hour we'll
The only version of this that wasn't
super jank was the original DQN, and it
was still not like amazing.
I figure out
the issue with this is
I think the issue with this is that the
policy gradient update is just a better
update rule than um
than the Q-learning update because the
Q-learning update's a quadratic loss.
Oh, and also the Q-learning update by
default is just the onestep bootstrap.
because you're estimating values instead
of actions, right?
Okay. So,
it's actually kind of easier
when you're not using the Q function
take action. Just using it as a target.
I think it's actually easier, right?
Because you can just throw HL Gaus on
the output continuous value to output.
I mean, we do have a way to apply
we do have a way to apply off policy
updates
um
without a Q function, right? It's called
behavioral cloning.
let's say that you train the Q function
with whatever objective you're going to
do.
Wait, hang on. Does this solve it?
Wait, wait. The reason that you can't
apply off policy updates is because of
the value function, right? It's not
because of the policy. You can apply
whatever the heck updates you want to
the policy. It's just that the uh the
value function will get stale.
if we actually have an action condition
value function, we apply retrace.
Well, it prevents us from applying off
policy updates.
I'm trying to fundamentally understand
like where and where like where off
policiness hurts you and where it
doesn't All right.
you have um your data that you collect
like
action
So if I want to learn from this
trajectory
behavioral cloning
works
matter where this comes from right
Of course,
I ask the LM that lies half the time.
Um
I mean if we think about it from first
principles though there's no way that it
can get stale right you're literally
just pushing
probabilities
towards a specific set of actions right
I believe it's the value function as
soon as you have a value function
baseline
plus
value
I don't think this is correct. Is it?
Unless I have a major error here.
You can do behavioral cloning and you
can write behavioral cloning as just a
different update,
a different waiting of the same update.
That doesn't seem correct to me.
was under the impression it's just the
value function.
But you can just do this with
I don't think this is correct.
Yeah. So, okay. So, this is fine.
Okay. But I don't think this implies
that
So I see why in the original derivation
here, right? And this is this is written
as a pro like under probability of
trajectory with the current
um the current policy. You immediately
encode the on policy assumption here.
But if you look at the final rule, this
is the same as behavioral clothing,
right?
And behavioral cloning works with any
data.
There's no on policy assumption. It's
just a match actions.
I think the actual on policy like the
actual problem comes from the value
function getting scale doesn't it?
I don't think this is correct.
Let me see if I find an error.
But you can do this online as well. This
doesn't matter.
Expected return on policy.
Yeah, you're just trying to match
action.
literally the same freaking objective,
right?
It's the same freaking objective.
It's just that you're waiting by the
returns here.
whether it is true or not this
encoding here is is the major problem
because what happens right
is DQN is just written without this
dependence on trajectories.
If you look up DQN,
you'll see it's like a one-step
bootstrap. You just get around this
problem,
right? This is a onestep bootstrap. This
is the target. Yeah, there you go.
Onestep bootstrap here.
So there's no like, oh, the data wasn't
generated by the policy or whatever
because you're literally just looking at
um state action errors, transitions.
you're looking at individual
transitions.
Um, and then you're relying on the
bootstrap the bootstrap to chain it out.
But the thing is like this doesn't
actually freaking work, right?
Like this doesn't work at all.
And uh what people often do, right, is
they'll write out like they'll write
this out for a few steps. Like I think
Rainbow, they write this out for three
steps. So it's a three-step bootstrap.
Uh that is actually off policy, right?
Because the data there, those three
straps don't necessarily come from the
original policy you have. So you should
have the identical problem. And then
what you do is you do something like
retrace that uses uh important sampling.
But important sampling doesn't magically
fix the issue. It basically just like
downweights off policy data.
So like in the worst case you converge
back to this. If you have fully off
policy data, you converge back to this.
So I think this is the
the core problem
like you really really need this
multi-step estimate.
In fact, we need it for like six plus
steps in the on policy.
Probably helps in the off policy case if
you could do it correctly.
Um, we really need this multi-step
estimate,
but like all the methods actually under
the hood, they kind of just punt on it,
I think I might have stacked meetings
for the rest of the day.
Yeah, I do. Okay.
Uh, I'll end stream here. I suppose
there will be longer stream tomorrow,
but I have a whole bunch of meetings
throughout the rest of today.
I really want to get
I really want to like figure this out. I
want to get this figured out
because it really seems to me like
the base off policy algorithm makes
sense and works. It's just really bad
and then like all the things that
actually make it work or a hack that
depend on data being kind of on policy.
Okay. Well, thank you folks. I will be
back tomorrow. Buffer.ai for all the
things.
Our GitHub, join Discord, follow X, all
that. And I will